this is an example of a dashboard that
may be used by a software asset manager
to provide a quick view into vital
information about the system software
assets in order to reduce license cost
and audit exposure
the information found on this dashboard
leverages some of the integrations with
IBM control desk in order to import
discovered software assets and uses data
by applications like IBM endpoint
manager
in the left column shows the entitled
software that is not in use based on
software usage analysis this presents an
opportunity to reclaim licenses that
could be leveraged by other users
the next portlet shows a warning for
licenses that have been allocated over
the existing capacity presenting a
potential audit risk to view the
additional details of the audit risk the
report in a third portlet will help
reconcile the discovered capacity versus
the allocated capacity the final portlet
in the left column shows contracts that
are about to expire this allows the
software asset manager to make decisions
to renew the contract or begin planning
to sunset the usage and begin software
removal the first portlet in the right
column shows prohibited software within
the organization but has been discovered
on its assets this information can be
used to automate removal and any
remediation processes the final portlet
shows a breakdown of the list of vendors
that provide software this can be useful
invading future planning purposes for
volume discounts or Enterprise licenses